تتسع رقعه الاضرابات داخل القطاعات
الحيويه في بريطانيا اذا انضم المعلمون
الى الاضرابات الى جانب كل من الممرضين
وعمال السكاك الحديديه وسيضرب الاف
المعلمين في فبراير ومارس المقبلين بسبب
الخلاف حول الاجور على الرغم من التحذيرات
من ان الاضراب سيعرض الاطفال الضعفاء
خصوصا للخطر وسيطلق قاده النقابه الوطنيه
للتعليم اكبر اتحاد تعليمي في البلاد
اضرابا بعد نتائج التصويت من قبل اعضائه
البالغ عددهم 300,000 هذا وصوت مشاهدينا
تسعه من اصل 10 مدرسيين من نقابه المعلمين
لصالح الاضراب ويجتازت النقابه نسبه
الاقبال البالغه 50% التي يقتضيها القانون
قطاع التمريض في بريطانيا هو الاخر اعلن
ان اضرابهم سيستمر الى يوم غد الخميس
مضيفين اي الممرضون ان همم الاشخاص يتوفون
دون داعا في اشاره الى تسبب الحكومه في
هذه الوفيات كونها لا تستجيب لمطالب رفع
الاجور هذا وتواصل الحكومه رفض التحدث الى
الكليه الملكيه للتمريض بخصوص الاجور
والنقابات الصحيه الاخرى حول تحسين زياده
الاجور البالغه 1400 جنيه استرليني في
الفتره من عام 2022 الى
2023 التي قدمت لموظفي هيئه او قدمت لموظف
هيئه الخدمات الوطنيه الصحيه الى الجانب
الاخر مشاهدينا من القناه الانجليزيه حيث
يستعد الفرنسيون للاحتجاج غدا ليكون خميسا
اسود كما اطلق عليه في اضراب سيكون عام
ويتسبب بالغاء معظم رحلات القطارات في
البلاد غدا الخميس مع تاثر رحله الجويه
وتعطل مترو الانفاق بشكل كبير في باريس
وذلك طبعا احتجاجا على اصدار مشروع الرئيس
الفرنسي الخاص
نظام التقاعد الذي تعتبر احدى نقاته
الاساسيه رفع سن التقاعد الاعتمادي من 62
عاما حاليا الى 64 عاما بحلول عام 2030
[موسيقى]